whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up the LA City Council
which voted unanimously to ban medical
marijuana dispensaries and Cornell
Robinson Mayor Pro Tem of done North
Carolina who's bent on banning pants
that sag more than three inches below
the waist is a part of the culture that
greet drug sales drug addiction crime
and murder but this month we zero in on
New Jersey if you don't buckle your dog
in the car and New Jersey cops could
find you as much as a thousand dollars
there's also the possibility of up to
six months in jail officials say this
will boost safety for humans and critics
the drivers who don't use doggy
seatbelts to get busted by cops or
agents from the New Jersey Society for
the Prevention of Cruelty to Animals
which is funded solely by donations
grants requests and fines levied check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minded your own business